[Musique]
bonjour michel arrive merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin sur
rtl france nouveau conseil de défense
hier pas de restrictions ont vu pour
l'instant c'est ce qu'a dit le
porte-parole du gouvernement gabriela
talent écoutons le il n'y aura pas
d'évolution des restrictions nationales
cette semaine comme l'a annoncé le
premier ministre
nous avons nous avons avancé le
couvre-feu à 18 heures pour deux
semaines donnant sa chance à ce
couvre-feu
évidemment si la situation devait se
dégrader de manière importante d'autres
mesures nationales pourraient être
décidées pour michel larive c'est une
rumeur évidemment pour l'instant on
s'acheminerait vers un un confinement
pour les vacances de février compenser
vous pour l'instant de ce qu'on leur
fait des mesures prises
alors il est vrai que le gouvernement
est un porte-parole le gouvernement a
des informations que nous n'avons
peut-être pas il décide de lui on sent
en confiance maintenant nous nous avons
le droit parce que nous sommes en
position de critiquer aussi ce qu'il se
passe et à des choses qui me paraissent
moi aberrante notamment dans le domaine
de la culture où on peut voir que
d'entre eux dans d'autres pays des
protocoles sont à pitié des protocoles
qui fonctionne je parlais de barcelone
notamment
et puis puis les aberrations vous savez
que je suis député de l'ariège donc dans
une zone de montagne ont couvert les
rentrées chez des commerçants dans une
station de style mais en sortant dehors
vous ne pourrez pas faire du ski il ya
quelque chose qui est une espèce de
d'incohérences dans des mesures qui sont
prises et puis et puis et puis j'ai
envie de dire il va bien falloir un
moment donné planifier anticiper et se
dire que malheureusement ce virus est là
pour encore un bout de temps eh bien il
faudrait commencer à construire une
espèce de modus vivendi qui fasse que
l'on en prenne pas nos concitoyens que
pour des zones économiques us ce sont
des humains ils ont besoin de relations
sociales jean besoin de culture qui est
une nourriture essentielle ils ont
besoin pour les étudiants de reprendre
les études de socialiser voilà la france
a besoin les français ont besoin de
vivre à nouveau tout en sachant être
responsable ce qu'ils ont prouvé depuis
le début de la quinzaine
donc pour vous anticipation ça veut pas
dire anticiper un prochain couvre-feu ou
un prochain confinement mais c'est
mettre en place des mesures justement
pour pouvoir vivre normalement à long
terme puisque aux virus apparemment sera
là et même si la situation semble en
tout cas empirer alors attendez je viens
de vous dire que le gouvernement a
peut-être des informations que moi je
n'ai pas donc s'il faut confinés par
mesure de responsabilité je suis
responsable nous sommes responsables
donc à partir heureusement ainsi le
gouvernement a de données qui me dit il
faut conjuguer il faut confirmer
d'accord mais maintenant l'idée c'est de
ne pas enfermer la france de façon
alternative de confinement déconfinement
confinement déconfinement un moment
donné il va bien falloir essayer de
construire ce modus vivendi qui fera que
lorsque nous sommes confinés
nous construisons notre les confinements
et nous construisons une manière de
vivre avec ce virus
si j'espère disparaître a lui aussi vu
ça on n'en sait rien pour l'instant
parlant des contrôles aux frontières
depuis lundi des tests pcr négatifs sont
obligatoires pour les étrangers au rheu
ils doivent être mis à l'isolément pour
une période de sept jours
or on le voit ça marche pas vraiment
il n'y a pas de contrôles réalisés
notamment sur ses isolement pour vous
c'est quoi c'est juste de la
communication ou comment vous jugez
cette politique de contrôle des
frontières c'est de la communication et
de la demi mesure parce que si nous
français faisons ceci soit maintenant
quelqu'un qui veut rentrer dans le jeu
il peut rentrer par 27 pays ou dans les
spas tchèque dans l'espace schengen un
peu moins mais en tout cas je peux
rentrer dans lieu et le soin qu'il est
dans l'ue veut aller où il veut il peut
l'intérieur de lieux si quelqu'un décide
et et d'atterrir en espagne eh ben il
peut prendre le train pour arriver par
barcelone ou par aux parents d'aller en
france sans problème
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire il faut
imposer des restrictions au niveau des
pays européens ça va être l'objet date
d'ailleurs de discussion au conseil
européen aujourd'hui 1 il faut être
cohérent il faut être cohérent c'est à
dire que il faut essayer d'harmoniser
nos politiques européennes de manière à
ce que vous voyez par exemple la
solution qui est proposée par ce
gouvernement est de 2,7 à battre le
moule le dise obsolète
jean-louis doivent rien on a vu cette
semaine a accusé l'exécutif de l'avoir
incité à reporter les élections
régionales après la présidentielle
l'ancien ministre était chargé de
rédiger un rapport on s'en souvient sur
la tenue de ces élections dans le
contexte sanitaire
voici ce qu'il a dit lors d'une audition
récemment sénat regarder ce qui était à
l'origine de cette réflexion avait un
souhait que j'ai deviné qui était de
reporter ces élections départementales
et régionales a beaucoup plus tard après
l'élection présidentielle
alors elles sont prévues en juin ils ont
déjà été reportés un ces élections
régionales et départementales est ce que
vous vous inquiétez de cet éventuel
report là aussi il ya des informations
que nous n'avons vous et - peut-être pas
maintenant ce que je sais c'est que le
texte vient de passer au sénat et que
les sénateurs ont fait en sorte de
quelque part verrouiller le texte pour
garantir au moins ne tenu de ce que tu
es en juin
maintenant le texte sera examiné mardi
en première lecture de la musique dessus
de bruxelles à avant d'aller d'aller à
l'assemblée nationale alors nous nous
verrons bien mais la problématique n'est
pas seulement le jour du vote vous
comprenez que lorsqu'il y a des
élections il faut qu'il y ait la
possibilité de faire campagne et dans
des conditions qui sont les nôtres c'est
à dire la condition de qu'ovide il n'est
pas question d'organiser sûrement des
grands meetings ou d'autres réunions
publiques
ça va être une donc une campagne à
minima au niveau des contacts sociaux
très virtuel il ya toute une
organisation à avoir et donc qu'il n'ya
pas de là va bien falloir que les
décisions se prennent très rapidement et
on suivra cela évidemment merci beaucoup
michel arrive d'avoir répondu ce matin à
nos questions en direct sur rtl france